ton bruno oui ça va être des
commencements telle est ma terre comme
toujours les bataves à dire complètement
oui j'ai pas du tout donné ta n'y a pas
de petite amie en ce moment non non je
suis célibataire célibataire et oui
célibataire est avec toi pour l'instant
[Applaudissements]
branche moi au moins je ne sais pas à
ton genre c'est ça bruno non c'est
géraldine charniére oxylane on est
intelligent mais le voilà assez torturée
quoi tend à 18 ans style oui non
il va donc y lire tout le ballon une
barrette ya une barrette wave muscat et
d'hélium il me doit de l'argent
il n'a jamais été sur tf1
the voice marouane ou marron avec leurs
hôtes moi je voulais faire en fait avec
sa diva du pas envie de faire sourire
les symboles sont pas non je suis
patient et toi doc gynéco les oreilles
il faudra qu'ils aient plus de musique
urbaine un peu plein de un peu plus de
hip hop et à ce moment là oui c'est trop
variété là il ya ça manque de punch et
des coutumes et des parfums
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aime trop tu kiffes et george michael
fut sur wii depuis wam web et parlez-moi
wake me up before you go go
je vous jure il faut laisser une caméra
sur les deux la wii fit de lui le futur
google n'ont pas du tout les deux à côté
c'est non mais elle a connu sa soeur à
koné george michael qui fait george
michael howard pas d'âge qui fait c'est
un grand mot je connais c'est quoi c'est
pas comme j'ai des comptes à lui faire
une petite confidence sur le plateau de
salut les dernières samedi dernier sur
ton couple à l'époque grecque turque
avec christine angot oui maintenant chez
laurent ok ça a beaucoup fait parler
ce que tu as dit regarde ça fesait
venons est ce que vous allez faire votre
promotion chez laurent ruquier
forcément vous allez recroiser votre ex
christine angot et non mais tu sais la
meuf à charlie parce qu'en fait elle
sort avec le mets mon l'un de mes
meilleurs amis il ya quand même eu une
aventure avec le style en gros
l'aventuré c'est l'aventuré bons échos
au sujet de christine angot
vous avez dit ce que j'aimais chez elle
c'est son côté veuve noire [ __ ] j'ai
adoré l'idée de pouvoir travailler avec
elle toujours la relation avec elle ou
pas la dernière fois que je les ai vus
parce qu'elle vit pas loin de chez moi
dans le 18e
on a pris un thé mais c'est une relation
avec quelques complètement et
professionnelles et amicales avec j'ai
passé vraiment sur une connexion c'est
une personne avec laquelle j'ai j'ai
beaucoup appris ouais je laime beaucoup
dans le censeur elle a coûté ton album
amitié lie terme mais ils % tolérant à
l'écouté ou pas je juin on a travaillé
ensemble sur peut-être un titre ou deux
très bien d'ailleurs vous étiez un beau
personnage de roman fractionné continent
go dans le marché des amants ne sais pas
moi c'est l'autre
ah oui adacore bamert silva c'est tout
elle